Speaker 1: Welcome back to The David
Pakman Show. I am Jessy Dallimore,
host of the dollar more daily on the youtubes.
Listen, fox News. If they're good at anything,
it is running interference for Republicans. It's
running interference maybe chiefly for Donald
trump. And they will continue their lies about
Republican policy for as long as they can. And
this doesn't just come from the in the in the
infotainment side, the entertainment side of
Fox News. Your Tucker Carlson's your your Laura
Ingraham's your Sean Hannity's it all. It also
comes from the the news site Harris Faulkner. So
I want to talk about today. Right now there's a
budget battle. There's the debt ceiling fight that
we're in. The threat to shut down the government.
And there's a lot of talk about where this debt
came from and who's responsible for this debt.
And Republicans would have you believe that they
are all all about being good stewards of the
people's money, being being responsible spenders
and making sure that everything's paid for.
All while supporting Donald Trump and
getting in bed with Donald Trump and
his insane tax cuts for the rich
that took place in 2017 or so.
That led to 1 to 1 and a half trillion dollar
deficits every year of his presidency. And
that was before COVID. That was before all of the
supplemental spending that took place around that.
So when they talk about the deficit, I want to
say this upfront before you hear her propaganda
and her lies, when they talk about all the
Democrats just want to spend, spend, spend.
But they don't tell you that Donald Trump himself
in one term is responsible for roughly 25% of the
entire national debt of the United States. A
man who in 2015 or 2016, prior to being elected
to office, gave an interview with Bob Woodward
at The Washington Post and made the bold claim
that he was going to pay off the entire national
debt inside of eight years. And instead he's now
responsible for 25% of the overall debt. But you
wouldn't know that if you only watched Fox News.
If your parents are people who watch Fox News as
your grandparents or people who watch Fox News,
they'll buy this hook, line and sinker the same
way Americans bought that trickle down economics
works. Reaganomics. Oh, it's a godsend. That's
how. That's how you build back a strong economy.
It's all lies. And it gets told over
and over and over and over again,
to the point where people start believing it in
the face of insurmountable evidence that it is
false and history, for that matter. Watch. Harris
Faulkner selling a just vile, sinister lie here.
Speaker 2: At issue, the money is coming out
of the programs faster than it's going in. The
Congressional Budget Office report Social
Security is headed for bankruptcy without
legislative action to save it. It looks like
it will run dry within the next ten years. That
would automatically cut benefits by 23% for every
single American who needs those programs. Medicare
funding is vanishing even faster. The timing of
all of this, of trying to figure out what to do
comes during a fierce battle. As you know, it's
happening in our nation's capital over spending,
the debt growing precipitously. The standoff
between Republican lawmakers and the White
House over raising the borrowing limit.
Democrats want to do what they do spend,
spend, spend. Republicans want to slash and save.
Speaker 1: Democrats want to do what they do.
Spend, spend, spend. And Republicans want to
slash and save. You think Harris Faulkner,
Do you think that's what's happening here?
Republicans want to. They want to slash and save
while we have a nearly $1 trillion
military budget every single year. Listen,
I spent many years in the United States Marine
Corps proud. I'm proud of my service. But we
don't need $1,000,000,000,000 annual defense
budget because what? What are we defending?
There is no there there's not a massive war taking
place. We don't need to fund the conflict. $1,000
billion every single year, year in and year out.
But Republicans are responsible with the money.
They want to reorganize Social Security.
They want to raise the retirement age.
It is all gross and sinister because
people fall for it. Most importantly,
it's bad because of that, because they have a
captive audience with their their their aging
out audience of boomers who believe this crap.
Shame on you, Harris Faulkner. Shame on you